we're told to solve and graph the
solution for the system of equations
right here and the first thing that
jumps out at me is that we might be able
to eliminate one of the variables and if
we just focus on the X we have a 4x here
and we have a 2x right here if we were
just add them right now we would get a
6x so that wouldn't eliminate it but if
we can multiply this 2 X by negative 2
it'll become a negative 4x and then when
you add it they would cancel out so
let's multiply this equation the second
equation by negative 2 so I'm going to
multiply both sides of this equation by
negative 2 and the whole motivation is
so that this 2x becomes a negative 4x
and of course I can't just multiply only
the 2x anything I do to the left hand
side of the equation I have to do to
every term and I have to do to both
sides of the equation so the second
equation becomes negative 4x that's
negative 2 times 2x plus we have
negative 2 times negative y which is
plus 2i is equal to 2.5 times negative 2
is equal to negative 5 I just rewrote
the second equation multiplying both
sides by negative 2 now this top
equation I'll write it on the bottom now
we have 4x minus 2y is equal to positive
5 and now we can eliminate we can say
hey look the negative 4x and the
positive 4x should cancel out or they
will cancel out so let's add these two
equations let's add the left side to the
left side the right side to the right
side and we can do that because these
two things are equal we're doing the
same thing to both sides of the equation
so what do we get
if we take our negative 4x plus our 4x
well those cancel out so you're left
with nothing maybe I can write a zero
there 0x if you want and then you have
your plus 2y and your negative 2i those
also cancel out so you're also left with
0y and then that equals negative 5 plus
5 is equal to 0 so you have just have
this 2 just simplifies to 0 equals 0
which is true but it's kind of bizarre
we had all these X's and Y's everything
everything canceled out so let's explore
this a little bit more let's graph it
and see what this is 0 equals 0 is
telling us when we tried to solve the
system of equations so let me graph let
me graph this top guy I'll do it in blue
so right now it's in standard
let's put it in slope intercept form so
we have 4x minus 2y is equal to 5 let's
subtract 4x from both sides subtract 4x
I want the X terms on the right-hand
side so that I'm left with negative 2y
is equal to negative 4x plus 5 now we
can divide both sides by negative 2 by
negative 2 and we are left with Y is
equal to is equal to positive 2x right
that's positive 2x 4 minus 2 point 5
minus 2 point 5 so let's graph that the
y-intercept is negative 2 & a half so
negative 2 and 1/2 right there and then
it has a slope of 2 so if we move up 1
we go if we move up in the X direction
well if we move to the right one in the
positive x-direction we will move up 2
so 1/2 right there and if we were to do
it again we move up 1 2 just like that
so the line is going to look something
like this try my best to draw a straight
line
this is the hardest part about a lot of
these problems there you go so that's
the top equation now let me draw the
bottom equation let me draw and I'll do
it in in this green color so this bottom
equation was 2x minus y is equal to 2.5
and we can subtract 2x from both sides
let's subtract 2x from both sides
the left-hand side becomes negative y is
equal to 2x plus or is equal to negative
2x plus 2.5 now let's multiply or divide
both sides by negative 1 and you get Y
is equal to positive 2x minus 2.5 and
let's try to graph this and you already
might notice something interesting about
these two equations you try to graph
this the y-intercept is at negative two
point five right there the slope is two
so it's going to be this exact same line
it's going to be this exact same line
and you saw that algebraically I didn't
have to graph it these two lines have
the exact same equation when you put
them when you put them in slope
intercept form that's the first equation
that's the second equation so with the
zero equals zero is telling us is
actually that these are the same line
that these actually have an infinite
number of solutions any point on this
line which is both of those lines will
satisfy both of these equations you give
me an arbitrary y solve for x in the top
equation that that x and y will also
satisfy the bottom equation so this
actually has an infinite number of
solutions these are the same line